environnement a présenté une nouvelle
semaine dédiée à cette cause qui se met
en place à trappes depuis aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au 20 avril des ateliers des
expositions sont proposées
ainsi cet après midi à la salle jean
baptiste clément le public le plus
souvent familiales étaient conviés
écoutez thomas sûrs dix élus en charge
de l'urbanisme de l'environnement et de
la qualité de vie il nous parle des
différents temps forts de cet événement
il ya trois ans exactement
le printemps est important donc aux
lampes sous forme d'ateliers cet après
midi donc ce mercredi 13 avril de 14
heures à 17 heures les ateliers des jeux
tout public
le deuxième temps c'est qu'effectivement
on va voir entrer des habitants
notamment le lundi 18 avril directement
en lien avec les centres sociaux
et puis les bailleurs aux pieds les
immeubles et ils veulent que liés
notamment de récupération d'eau de pour
le jardin et sorties familles on va voir
des taxes et cotisations sur le tri la
propreté permettre aussi de découvrir
l'art et la nature impopulaires naturel
on n'en parle pas assez
le troisième temps fort finalement c'est
le mercredi 20 avril donc il va clôturer
cette semaine de l'environnement qu'on a
voulu à cheval entre la part de en
vacances scolaires de main contre l'eire
qu'on ne puisse pas les mêmes publics
mais elle aura donc son point d'orgue le
mercredi 20 avril à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique et de danse avec la
clôture de la semaine de l'environnement
et c'est bien évidemment une séance
ouverte aux habitantes l'espace jeunes
et les femmes de loisirs et
participeront c'est ouvert à tous et on
analyse bien évidemment le plus grand
nombre de venir se renseigner auprès de
demain